hi guys how are you doing
hi i am very happy to talk to you i had
so much fun with this show i just
thought
it was just so sweet and fun and i'm
curious especially for reginald i mean
when you did turner and hooch
could you ever have imagined that you'd
be reprising this character of all the
characters you've played
i had no idea it was a very special
treat to know that i'd come back and do
this role again
you know after so long that it was like
getting into a
you know it was getting into a new
project it was it was kind of a nice
feeling
and i had never done anything like that
before where i come and recreate
the role that i played before and it was
nice but what helped a lot was
the other actors and how they helped me
transition into this this new thing
i really appreciate the talent and
ability of the
new actors that really helped me so that
was a good thing
when this idea came your way did you
think they were joking
about bringing you back and playing this
character and coming back to this world
no well i was kind of thrilled because
i'd never done anything like this before
and it was kind of nice to know that
they wanted me to be involved in this
you know and uh i i
so so blessed to have the opportunity to
be in this
and with the other actors and you know i
i i was humbled
by the experience i really was
what was your reaction to learning that
not only would your character have
outlived
hoot but also turner
well going into the original was it was
a unique experience for me too because
it was a supporting role and
it was my first and it was it was fun to
do but to come back and do it again
in this tv show was a whole different
experience for me a whole different
attitude
you know and working with the new actors
and who
uh you know elevated this to the
experience that it is
was very special for me and i i really
appreciate them having me involved in
this
and to work with the other ex who i know
are going to be superstars when this
comes on
and i was happy to be a part of it
really
lindsay for you when this opportunity
came your way
what was your reaction were you familiar
with the movie did you immediately
wonder if this involved hazard pay for
all the dog drool
like how does that work
um yeah well you know i was a fan of the
of the original movie i was like
two when it came out so i watched later
in life but um
you know i was sorry reg it's okay we
need you there buddy
it's all right baby but i i
i you know it's a beloved film for a
reason and so
it definitely interested me but having
uh
josh's the lead was was something
that i was actually very interested in
and i've known him since i was a kid and
we've worked together before
so when i was asked to read with him and
do a chemistry read as siblings it was
like a really a no-brainer i also
am a mom now in real life and so to play
a mom
a complex mother who's got
you know a lot of figure out also was an
interesting thing for me at the time
so and then there's the dog of it all
so i mean is it
is it kind of nice to not be the one
that has to
always have the dog with them that you
can sort of just send it off with josh
and not worry about it
the dogs are really really strong like i
think that people don't quite understand
the physical
aspects of holding that dog's leash
um and the calm the physicality of
playing the comedy
you know josh is really he is taking the
brunt of that
and the the the few episodes in which
hooch was with me more
i was sore i was i
like i my shoulders and my elbows my
joints hurt from
from from holding his leash and um
i mean there was one time he took off in
the woods and i had to let the leash go
because i
i tried to keep up for a bit but he's
too strong
i i love that uh your character lindsay
has
her own brand of chaos going on in her
life i mean she's
trying to handle and deal with so many
things
what do you love about that aspect of
the character
and really getting to juggle so much
stuff
i always try i mean sometimes it's
written the writing is very full
of life but i i also try and have as
many
because i'm a mom in real life so i know
that i'm rarely sitting down
doing nothing i'm i'm doing a million
things at the same time so
having all of i mean laura's got a
million animals she's got she's a single
mom
she's a vet tech veterinarian she's
studying for her
license like there's so i always tried
to hold as many props put things away
like what else am i doing besides
talking in the scene
um there's of course the rare beautiful
moments like with reg's character where
we're just sort of like reminiscing
about dad and just kind of taking that
time
but the chaos of laura's house is real
and they did a fantastic job with the
with the set decorations because it is
chaos
yeah i mean we hear all these stories
about you know never working with
animals and children and she's working
with a lot of animals and
one child but still it seems like
there's a lot to juggle for her
it's great you know it's uh it brings a
lot of life you know i
remember that the parrot who like flew
at me
on the phone with josh and a parent
coming at me you know
it's great i i i welcome the chaos um
you know it comes with its challenges of
course but i think that those just make
you better at
a better actor really original how do
you feel about
the little literal decades of playing
police officers that you've had
is it something that you know it has
been
a task playing different i never thought
that in my career i'd be playing cops
in every other film that i do you know
but uh
it's okay it's it's it i tried to make
everyone different every character
police officer that i played i tried to
make it different and um
i guess people see me as a police
officer and you know even the
even real police officers say come up to
me and say give me a picture or
something like that
which i think is very honorable you know
because what they have to do
is a really tough job and for me to play
to them to respect me for what i for
betraying them
you know it was a good thing and i i
appreciate that and i
you know it's it's just a joy to portray
different
police officers and different genres i i
i
i'm humbled by it because what their job
is very difficult to do
and that and i practice to trade
something that gives them
credit you know i'm glad to apply to
that and i appreciate that so
i'm happy to do it so many people and
families
and me fell in love with you and your
character on family matters
what are your fondest memories of
playing that character and working with
with the cast of family matters when you
did that show lord have mercy uh
playing the father of uh three kids uh
you know and it was very special i
when i i got married so i had when i
when i first portrayed the role it was
coming and i had to learn how to be a
father and you know and uh
watch those kids grow up and you know it
was really cool and i learned a lot you
know and i enjoy it we're still friends
today
i never whenever i did a project i
always tried to do
a positive you know uh performance of it
because being negative on the set
is really difficult to be and to have to
perform
so i always kept a good attitude with
everybody on the show on the set
because that's important because that
that helped the characters
situation to flow better into the
situation and i
i'm very thankful that everybody that i
work with was able to experience
a good time but you know it's just
a unique experience to work with actors
that you never met before and whatnot
and
turner and hooch you know the actors
that i work with
were excellent they made me feel so
comfortable i made me feel so homework
and uh i i thank them for that you know
that's uh
that's a testament to the casting people
because they cast the right people
you know and i i enjoyed every moment of
it
yeah i certainly see similarities
between the two shows too especially
with the family dynamic because it does
have that sense of you know just it's
it's just sweet and fun
and nice and it makes you feel good to
watch a show like this does make you
feel good you know
feel that way with a lot of shows around
the time family matters
that's why it's going to be a big hit
this show because it brings your family
together
and enjoy watching it with family you
know and
if this is a family-oriented uh script
you know you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna
gravitate to it and i think it's it's
got that
lindsay i love the work that you did on
nikita which was a very very different
show
than this one but i love that your
character
also you know aside from being a sister
and a mother
wants to be involved and be more
hands-on and
i'm curious will she be getting into
some trouble and some danger
this season especially as they dig into
whatever her father was up to yes laura
gets into some trouble
uh laura is a what's beautiful is that
as
as the season goes on the writers were
wonderful to
write her ambition and her her
her inability to let something go in a
beautiful way
um she's very determined woman and uh
she gets into some trouble
the cool thing is is that i got to get
into the action of
stuff without having to be like a cool
spy
like i could i could do things you know
i remember like running towards a truck
and like having to throw things out of
it to get into it and i
i could use the comedy of it all because
laura is a veterinarian technician
like she's not used to like running from
bad guys so it's the comedy of like yeah
i get rid of this stuff and i gotta how
does this truck work and
so the action was a completely different
skill set on this show than nikita
where i had to look cool all the time
and look stealthy and
and sly and here i can just like
be kind of just like a regular person
trying to catch up to all the action and
it was a really fun
experience yeah i really love the
physical comedy of this show
and it's one of those things where you
know it's it seems like really
tricky and difficult to do but when you
do it right
the audience sort of takes it for
granted because it's just fun to watch
so is that something that that you have
taken to with the physical comedy aspect
of it is it something that you've had
to sort of adjust to because it is very
different
oh completely i mean every movement that
laura does
was totally counterintuitive than you
know the last show
of like always making sure that i moved
with purpose
and like a pro and a trained assassin
you know and here laura is who's never
she's just like i mean the way that she
runs the way she's
riding her bmx bike trying to keep up
with her kid and like
i mean it was just comedy gold because
it was those moments
in every moment i could just just like
you know
juggling toys and laundry and like you
know the physicality was really really
fun
what can you say about where your
character is at this point
in his life now that we catch back up
with him again
well aside from being older you know he
has a whole bunch of uh
new individuals to get used to uh
but he's still the same character that
he was in the original tournament whose
movie
he's there to support his partner and to
make sure everything is okay
and uh in this day he's trying he wants
to find out who
his partner's killer is and uh you know
and that's
and when he find finally finds out you
know uh he's very thankful
and it's time to move on but we got this
solved
we have the reason why tom died and
whatnot we got the killer
and uh who knows what's next for this
this
this whole project uh you know hopefully
it'll last for five six years from now
because i think all the
the characters are very interesting
still and the new character is even more
interesting to find out what happens
with this doll
and his the many things he has to go
through in life so
i'm excited about this project so we
shall see
yeah i mean both of you guys have done
enough projects that you know that
this business is so weird and
unpredictable that you never know what's
going to happen with the show or how
long you get to play a character
so is it hard to you know think about
and
make a wish list for what your character
could do in the future when you don't
know
if they're gonna have a future is that
hard to navigate especially when you
guys are clearly having so much fun
well i'm older so i can't do much but uh
what they give me to do i'll i'll gladly
try to portray it but uh
i think uh it's up to lindsay and the
group to uh
give this show the the the grit that it
needs so
and she's very very capable of doing
that so
thank you reg writers the writers have
definitely have really great ideas for
the next season and i
i hope we can do them because i feel
like we've just gotten started
beautiful yeah how how much of this did
you know
ahead of time i mean did you know how
all of this would play out when you
started the season were you as
curious as to what was going on with
this case that
your father was pursuing or did you have
those answers
i didn't know like super specific
details
um and i didn't want to know because i
was just trying to like task at hand
what laura was going through in the
episodes but yes that's what
when i signed on i was told that
you know there's more to this to this
character than
um an overworked single mom who's just
bringing a dog over that there's
there's gonna be a lot of purpose in her
future
and um and they lived up to that i think
there's even more to explore
with regeneized you know relationship
together and what
he does as a mayor and jeremy growing up
every every episode he got older and
more involved
also in the case so and then also the
relationship between scott and laura i
mean i think that this
this investigation just totally brought
them together
in a new way that was so sweet and
adorable i think it's a very special
show i think people are going to
gravitate
to it very easily you know because
there's so many things to like about the
show
i think people are going to grab people
it's going to be it's going to be great
that's all i got to say
lindsay what does it like to form that
bond with with jeremy i mean you're
thrown into
having to figure out that relationship
with a kid
what's it been like to work with him
working with jeremy
is very special he's this very sweet kid
and
two and one thing i watched i watched he
and the dog
as they interacted and whatnot and it
was really fabulous
i think people are going to love the way
he reacts to these animals and whatnot i
think
it's very special a positive young actor
he's really promising
i think uh people are gonna love him
with these animals i think they are
you know so it was it was just a
pleasure watching him do his thing you
know
there is a responsibility as a as a as
an actor who plays a parent i think
to make sure your tv kid is safe feels
safe and comfortable
it's really this is i've played a mom
before
but this is the longest running like
show to play a mom so i mean jeremy and
i were together
almost every day for eight months um and
so i don't take that responsibility
lightly you know it's just a really
important job and i
as a mom i know if this was my kid on a
set
doing a job at a young age like i would
want them to be
feeling confident and safe and
and having fun you know i realized at a
certain point i was like
why am i sitting here doing emails
between takes i need to go play a card
game with jeremy because
you know like i want to keep him so
there's i do feel like i take that
responsibility really
really um strongly yeah
lindsey what what in what ways would you
say your character
is most like you how is she least like
you and
is there a quality of hers that you wish
you had
i think she's a lot like me um
i i to be totally honest when i shot the
pilot
i thought i knew who she was i was
playing this version of laura
um who was a little bit more
single-minded just dealing with the
death of the father
and then as the story continued i just
realized
that she was quirky like she just had
more going on and i tried to bring a
little bit more of that into the show
i think the writing i think this like
beautiful marriage of me
finding more comedy in the character and
the writing um
supporting that we the writers and i
kind of found this beautiful
dance that we did um that was just like
who is laura like she's not just the
sister like what is her
weird quirks and when you meet grady her
ex-husband
and when you see that side of like who
she was when she was married and how
that
relationship affected her you start to
understand laura a lot more so um
yeah i wouldn't equality i wish i was
more like her i mean
gosh she is an ambitious person to be
studying for a veterinarian license with
like 300 animals and a kid and like
doing it all alone
i mean that's i don't know what you did
but you reminded me a lot of tom
in the in the movie you know you did
your your mannerisms or something was
like well a lot like his i don't know if
you studied him
but uh he reminded me of him yeah you
did
so thank you appreciate that yep
yeah i mean original did you go back and
watch the original movie at all did you
want to i haven't seen the original
you've been a long time but i remember
i remember it you know but uh what was
you know
what was special about it was seeing the
difference between the two
genres and um i had a wife in the
original movie my wife was played by
angela bassett
and they cut her out you know but um
it was fun watching the the transition
from the movie to the tv thing
and i think they didn't miss a beat i
think it's going to even be better
you know i think people turner who's
going to be around a long time
because people are going to fall in love
with the dog like we did you know and i
think uh
he's going to be very she's going to be
a star that's all i say
well i i love you guys in this i think
that this show is so sweet and fun and
so i appreciate you talking to me about
it
oh that's really nice thank you so much
thank you so much